>> Tucker: YOU HAVE WAITED ALL
WEEK.
TIME FOR FINAL EXAM, WHERE THE
BEST INFORMED PEOPLE IN THE NEWS
BUSINESS SIT ACROSS FROM ONE
ANOTHER AT A SET TO DETERMINE
WHO IS THE BEST INFORMED PERSON
IN THE NEWS BUSINESS.
THIS WEEK'S CONTESTANTS, KRISTIN
FISHER AND THE HOST OF SPECIAL
REPORT, BRET BAIER.
NOW, YOU KNOW, YOU NEVER MISS AN
EPISODE, YOU KNOW THE RULES.
FOR VIEWERS JUST TUNING IN I'LL
REPEAT THEM.
BUZZERS, I ASK THE QUESTION, THE
FIRST ONE TO BUZZ IN GETS TO
ANSWER THE QUESTION.
MUST WAIT UNTIL I FINISH ASKING
THE QUESTION TO ANSWER IT.
CAN YOU ANSWER ONCE I
ACKNOWLEDGE YOU BY SAYING YOUR
NAME.
EACH CORRECT ANSWER WORTH ONE
POINT, EVERY INCORRECT DETRACTS
A POINT, BEST OF FIVE WINS.
>> MAKES SENSE.
WE'RE READY.
>> Tucker: GOOD LUCK.
THE ART WORLD WAS STUNNED THIS
WEEK WHEN A PAINTING BY THE
GRAFFITI ARTIST WAS SOLD AT
AUCTION.
SOMETHING ODD HAPPENED, ONCE THE
GAVEL CAME DOWN, WHAT WAS IT.
[BUZZER]
>> Tucker: BRET BAIER.
>> NO ONE BID.
>> Tucker: NO ONE BID.
DID NO ONE BID ON THE FAMOUS
GRAFFITI ARTIST BANKSY?
TO THE TAPE.
[APPLAUSE]
[BEEPING]
[EXCITED TALKING]
>> THIS WORK OF ART IS BEING
SHREDDED, THEY SAY IT ADDS ABOUT
50% TO THE VALUE.
>> THAT IS QUITE A BRILLIANT
THING.
>> Tucker: THAT IS A PRANK.
BUT ALL RIGHT.
QUESTION TWO.
THAT SAYS SOMETHING GOOD ABOUT
BOTH OF YOU, YOU AREN'T WATCHING
ART AUCTIONS DURING THE DAY.
YOU HAVE WORK TO DO.
IN IS A MULTIPLE CHOICE WE.
SINGER TAYLOR SWIFT HAS BECOME
POLITICAL AS YOU KNOW, URGING
HER FANS TO VOTE AGAINST
TENNESSEE REPUBLICAN MARCIA
BLACKBURN NEXT MONTH.
THE PRESIDENT RESPONDED BY
SAYING OF SWIFT, ONE OF THREE
THINGS.
WAS IT, A, TAYLOR SWIFT IS
OVERRATED.
B, I LIKE HER MUSIC LESS NOW.
OR, C, LOCK HER UP.
[BUZZER]
>> B.
HE LIKES HER 25% LESS.
>> Tucker: I THOUGHT IT WAS LOCK
HER UP.
TO THE TAPE.
>> MARCIA BLACKBURN IS DOING A
GOOD JOB IN TENNESSEE, I'M SURE
TAYLOR SWIFT HAS NOTHING OR
DOESN'T KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT HER.
AND LET'S SAY THAT I LIKE
TAYLOR'S MUSIC ABOUT 25% LESS
NOW.
>> Tucker: ALL RIGHT.
>> GOOD EFFORT.
>> WATCHING ALL OF THIS TAPE
FINALLY SUNK IN.
>> Tucker: ROUGHLY 25% LESS.
QUESTION THREE, ALSO TAKEN FROM
THE WORLD OF POP CULTURE, KANYE
WEST UNDER FIRE TODAY, FOR
SHOWING ALL OF AMERICA HIS EYE
PHONE'S PASS CODE ON LIVE
TELEVISION.
HE MET WITH THE PRESIDENT IN THE
WHITE HOUSE, KANYE TOOK OUT HIS
PHONE AND HIT THE SAME NUMBER 6
TIMES TO UNLOCK IT.
WHAT VERY UNSECURE NUMBER WAS
IT?
[BUZZER]
BRET BAIER.
>> ZERO.
NO, I DON'T KNOW HOW MANY ZEROS,
I THINK IT US 000000.
>> Tucker: ALL ZEROS.
>> YES.
>> Tucker: WAS IT ALL ZEROS?
>> WHAT WE WANT TO START WITH,
IS, I BROUGHT -- WOW.
>> NOT EXACTLY SECURE.
>> Tucker: THE JUDGES SAY THAT'S
ENOUGH ZEROS.
WE MIGHT BE LOOKING AT THE
COMEBACK STORY OF THE WEEK.
1 TO ZERO.
YOU ARE BACK TO STASIS.
>> GOOD EGG.
>> Tucker: WHICH FORMER AMERICAN
PRESIDENT WILL COME TO LIFE IN
THE FORM OF A 3-D HOLOGRAM IN
WASHINGTON?
KRISTIN.
>> REAGAN.
>> Tucker: REAGAN?
>> RAY BEGAN.
>> Tucker: A HOLOGRAM
AT HIS LIBRARY.
>> EVERY FOUR YEARS ALMOST EVERY
REPUBLICAN PRESIDENTIAL HOPEFUL
INVOKES THE SPIRIT OF PRESIDENT
REAGAN.
NOW AT HIS LIBRARY, THAT SPIRIT
HAS BECOME A VIRTUAL REALITY.
THREE HOLOGRAMS OF PRESIDENT
REAGAN WILL MAKE THEIR FIRST
APPEARANCE.
>> I'M NOT SURE THIS CONNECTED.
YOU SHOULD HAVE HOLOGRAMS IN
HERE.
>> TAKE MORE TIME OFF.
>> Tucker: LET'S GET THAT IN OUR
CONTRACT.
>> HAVE A FRIDAY OFF.
>> Tucker: FINAL QUESTION, THIS
ONE ALSO MULTIPLE CHOICE,
FRONTIER AIRLINES, KICKED OFF AN
ORLANDO WOMAN FROM ONE OF ITS
FLIGHTS AFTER SHE BOARDED THE
MANE WITH A PROHIBITED ANIMAL.
THIS MULTIPLE CHOICE.
WHAT KIND OF ANIMAL WAS IT?
WAS IT, A, A PYTHON --
>> NO, NO, NO!
>> TEN YARDS AND THE BALL.
>> Tucker: KRISTIN LOSES A
POINT, IT GOES TO BRETT.
>> COULD I GET THE RIGHT ANSWER.
>> Tucker: YOU COULD TIE IT UP
THEN WE NEED A TIEBREAKER.
>> ARE YOU HORRIBLY UNFAIR.
>> Tucker: THOSE ARE THE RULES,
LIKE THE ELECTORAL COLLEGE, IT'S
IN THE CONSTITUTION, YOU CAN'T
CHANGE IT.
BRETT, DID SHE REFUSE TO FLY
WITHOUT, A, A PYTHON, B, A
SQUIRREL, OR, C, A RACCOON?
>> A SQUIRREL.
>> Tucker: WAS IT A SQUIRREL?
>> A WOMAN WAS KICKED OFF A
FLIGHT AFTER BRINGING AN
EMOTIONAL SUPPORT SQUIRREL ON TO
THE PLANE.
FRONTIER AIRLINES ONLY ALLOWS
DOGS OR CATS.
THIS IS UNUSUAL.
>> EMOTIONAL SUPPORT SQUIRREL.
>> Tucker: I SEE IT WAS MULTIPLE
CHOICE.
>> I KNOW, I KNOW.
I GOT EXCITED.
>> Tucker: WE HAVE TO GO TO THE
TIEBREAKER.
WE HAVE THE SAME TIEBREAKING
QUESTION, OKAY?
IF YOU WATCH THE SHOW BEFORE,
YOU KNOW IT.
>> I DON'T.
>> Tucker: YES YOU DO.
HERE'S THE TIEBREAKER.
WHAT IS THE CAPITAL OF BURKINA
FAOSSO?
>> THIS IS YET?
>> Tucker:
>> HAS ANYBODY GOTTEN IT?
>> Tucker: NO.
>> I DON'T KNOW.
>> Tucker: IT IS WAGADUDU.
>> I WAS GOING TO SAY THAT.
>> Tucker: IN THIS RARE
INSTANCE, NEVER BEFORE SEEN --
WAIT, WE HAVE ONE MORE QUESTION.
WHAT IS THE CAPITAL OF
MADAGASAR?
>> MADAGASAR, THE CAPITAL.
>> Tucker: YES.
>> CAN YOU GOOGLE THAT?
>> I HAVE TWO THOUGHTS.
>> Tucker: OUR JUDGES ARE SAYING
NO REASONABLY INFORMED PERSON
SHOULD HAVE TO KNOW EITHER ONE
OF THOSE ANSWERS.
FOR THE FIRST TIME IN THE
HISTORY OF THE SHOW WE HAVE A
SPLIT DECISION, WE HAVE AN
ACTUAL TIE, IN WHICH BOTH OF YOU
GET A MEDAL, BOTH OF YOU CLAIM
THE VICTORY, BOTH OF YOU GO HOME
PROUD.
>> THIS IS QUITE THE MY LENNIAL.
>> Tucker: WE ONLY HAVE ONE MUG,
BUT THIS REQUIRES AT SOME POINT
IN THE NEXT 12 MONTHS YOU HAVE